Adrian whoa generale ski yahoo sports
NBA writer for the vertical they did
great really great coverage there
congrats first of all on that Adrian
that was well done on draft night yeah I
think we really enjoyed doing that show
it really is resonates with but the
audience we're going to do is get this
started late Thursday all right explain
the Kevin Durant recruiting tour how
many teams you really think have a
chance at Durant aside from Oklahoma
City well I reported a few days ago that
there were outside of Oklahoma City
there were five teams that they were
setting meetings up with that was Golden
State Celtics Miami Heat san antonio
spurs and who is the fifth I reported
City Clippers the Clippers where the 15
uh I think that oklahoma city remained a
very strong favorite it keeps him on a
one-year deal i'm told that even if you
were to sign elsewhere it was so dude on
a one-year deal and then come up at the
free agency again next year golden state
right now sources of Pompey is the one
team going into the meeting that he has
the most interest in the situation is
the most intriguing to him but Oklahoma
City remains a very strong favorite too
he's him on another one-year deal he
likes the trade that they made he was
very excited to get Victor Oladipo from
Orlando that's actually a plus for him
but I think it's going to be very hard
to go into a meeting and get into the
lead Oklahoma City he may not even take
this idiot probably fall unless he
decides he wants to go further with a
particular team but there's no schedule
right now for him to go on into an
account or well I'm trying to understand
what the what are they pitching Kevin
Durant
I think a lot of people are pitching for
next year i think a lot of the team
going in there feel like it's going to
be very hard to get it to leave right
now but a lot of teams my sense with
them is they feel like they're probably
pitching for next year's free agency
with it because i also if i'm kevin
durant the first person i go to is
russell westbrook to say you know what
how close are we or do you feel good
about this do you want to stay what are
you doing next year like that's where i
start if Russell Westbrook says look I'm
in if you're in I'm in and I'll stay
here if you stay here it does that is
that logical here Adrian get yes I
believe that a lot of the case goes to a
betty communication and they have a good
relationship and i think another factor
for Kevin Durant is he's going to share
the pressure the free agency pressure
with Russell Westbrook's next year that
if he were to leave next year I think
both he and Westbrook decided that they
were going to leave next year well it
makes me Kevin Durant very uh you know
he's very immersed in that community in
Oklahoma City he really cares about that
place she's really uh it's important to
a woman I don't think I think the
hardest part of leaving for him is for
walk away from that place and if he
didn't this year he'd have to do it all
alone let's say hypothetically next year
Russell decided to leave well Kevin's
got a little bit of it out they ate no
muscles leaving it doesn't make any
sense for me to sit stay now I think
they have a chance at Oklahoma City to
keep both of them for the long term uh
you know it would do what helped them to
win a championship next year or get to
the finals and make them feel like that
they can that they have a group that
could keep doing this but what happened
in Oklahoma City this year beating the
Spurs in the conference semis event you
know being up 3-1 I gold the state in
the fine and the Conference Finals it
let Kevin Durant and Russell Westbrook
know hey we're close we're closer than
maybe we even thought we were
coming in the last season when people
really pass them a distant third behind
the Spurs and Golden State he's Adrian
will generally yahoo sports the vertical
for the latest news on everything free
agent wise I had a couple of things here
Dwight Howard Joakim Noah Hassan
Whiteside Mike Conley Al Horford can you
do a thumbnail sketch here of all of
these guys starting with Dwight Howard
what do you see happening well the
market was white Howard to be is fairly
mysterious I I'm not talking to any
pieces I I don't get assessed as a max
contract out there for now it only takes
floor I think the market for gets going
to be kind of spotty you'll have
opportunities but wife wants like that
full four-year back I'm not sure that
out there for maybe a one here at secure
seal at a very high number but I don't
know that there's kids are going to go
for four years with him mike connelly Al
Horford assuming def bless you up
Horford finally dick for tuned in
Charlotte those are all players that
getting the five-year contract where
they currently are at a very high number
DeMar DeRozan next room it's going to be
hard to get any of those guys out of the
teacher with because this is to be a
comment he give me that fifth gear and
they can give you you know that annual
seven percent raise they could pay you
bored and I think that's a factor with
all those teams that if those guys are
going to get close to the max so the max
where they are I think all those teams
are very strong chance right now keep
the guys sign white size interesting i
think there are max offers out there for
Whiteside the Lakers have strong
interest Portland has a strong interest
in him Miami is going to have to pay my
ends of the tough financial situation to
be able to pay him and then pay Dewayne
Wade his market value and then watch out
with Miami they have a restricted free
agent Tyler Johnson who there's a lot of
interest in out there and
probably Johnson gets a big offer shoot
somebody will Miami be able to bastard
epin Adrian I know it's busy times for
you we do appreciate you joining us and
congrats again with the vertical yes I
so appreciated assignment Adrian woods
around ski yahoo sports with the
vertical the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience